ok so here are my predictions we
probably could dig in a little further
but this is a really nice set of mr.
start with ok so I'm hoping whatever I
get at the end is going to meet these
conditions let's start working here's my
arm here's my start off point I don't
have anything apart from these things
which are sort of general conditions I
don't know anything about this so I'm
going to take advantage of what I
disestablish afore and go after this guy
now we check out the derivative of tenax
right if y equals 10 names then the
derivative is equal to how's your memory
it's going to be a sec square right and
you can go ahead you can do the quotient
rule on side on cause you go ahead and
get that result step squared thanks so
far so good now what I want actually
that's the snow really what I'm going
for I want the derivative that's the
reciprocal of this right because I'm
after this tan inverse business so I
wanted to take the reciprocal using this
property up here DX on d y equals 1 on
sec squared X now let's just pause for a
second SEC squared of course is what
what is sex well it's whatever cause so
this I just written one over honey
because i swear i could have written cos
square but i'm actually not going to
it's not useful to me to do that because
you see about this for a second um I had
the derivative I have the darude but is
not in a very useful form to the Act the
moment doesn't yield me much insights
hard to work with so I want to sort of
massage you a little bit until it's a
little more helpful until I can see if
it follows these conditions on so I'm
gonna come over to this board how could
I work with this how can I work with as
well the original function is everything
in terms of tan ok dance dance ok so
here I have sec squared what piece of
knowledge do I have that helps me treads
let back and forth between sec and 10
yeah yeah this now you might be you
might be you know just got all these
things bubbling around your head and you
doing what this x squared 10th grade
only is I don't so I'm going to go back
to this guy but sine square
x plus cos squared X this is the actual
package identity equals one from which
you can get all the rest of them by
dividing through by whatever you like
now I want to get tan squared and sex
squared in there so what shall I divide
through by cos squared will do it right
so let's just go ahead this is going to
become tense wet right the cloth squared
is going to become one and then as we
just established the one with the [ __ ]
okay okay so seeing as that is the case
therefore I come back to this guy and I
say therefore DX on dy is equal to and I
make my substitution or sex squared I'm
going to write it in reverse order just
because it's kind of the young it's kind
of convention and it fits other patterns
will establish later now this is good
this is better because I know what tan x
is the first line i wrote down was my
definition for tan x it's why right and
that's kind of nice because this is a
derivative with respect to Y right
usually your differentiate with respect
to X everything's in terms of accidents
or now differentiating with respect to Y
so this is my result okay I've almost
there and then we can check our
predictions this is all a bit weird
because this line I've written here has
everything kind of in the reverse order
right I'm used to thinking like y equals
whatever I make that the subject so all
I have to do to translate from this just
liaison or normal is just to take all my
inputs and outputs and swap them right
so this is if x equals tan inverse of Y
if on the other hand y equals 10 inverse
of X just swapped my wives in my ex's my
inputs into outputs then I'm going to
swap the x and y here upside down and
here I just swapped that why that's
there for hours
tada now let's think does it work I am
expecting I originally we originally
predicted that F dash this guy would
always be positive because tan inverse
is a decreasing function does it match
yeah it does because of course no matter
what value would actually put in there
this guy is going to be positive so
you've got a positive divided by a
positive thumbs up what I saw we got x
equals can satisfy any real value can I
put anything in there and normally when
you have rational functions like you
keep old one how many vertical
asymptotes this thing will never have a
vertical asymptote why because x squared
this when dealing with real numbers
right so the smallest x square could
possibly be is zero so therefore the
smallest this composite of e is 1 over 1
right sorry this more the smallest that
they are denominator could be so
therefore perfidious that the whole
number would could be which leads to
next our next issue even function is
even yep because you look at the power
that's all you need to know does this
work this particular theme and the
answer is yes because the larger this
gets your denominator skyrockets so the
whole thing approaches 0 your
extremities yes last one test at 0
thumbs up 1 over 1 which is in fact the
greatest the gradient will be right that
was nice well done so what did we take
advantage of just rewind a little bit we
really need to establish this so we did
that before before we thought out trig
functions investor functions we have to
go through here we needed the derivative
of this clearly okay but this was
putting those two pieces together was
our bridge to get to our derivative of
this you had to be a little careful with
your own identities here and then
athletes this answer which is really
really nice by the way just really
quickly you might like to draw a really
brief sketch of this this gradient
function look like a nice easier think
about is it's a reciprocal of a function
i'm very very familiar with right now 1
plus x squared how would you verbally
describe that what kind of family of
curves is it it it's a parabola it's
gone cave up and it's being shifted one
unit so here is here's one plus X square
to take the reciprocal of this I know
that that's one what's the reciprocal of
11 okay so 1 over 1 plus X with also
passes through that vertex and then the
rest of that well this guy over here
Skye rocky but he's on the denominator
so he just drops down like that toward
zero and because it's an in function
there you go okay so that great light
there that's the gradient function of
tan inverse which exactly matches what
you predicted